The 3rd main category of connector are the data access connectors. And this is
as the name indicates, this, is where the connector is responsible for
dealing with access to some kind of data repository. Hence,
there is a communication service provided.
Moreover, the, the access connector may provide some kind of translation.
Surfaces could be character set translation, or something at a higher level.
Hence, there's a conversion service being provided. Some of the variations and
data access connectors include locality that is. Are the connectors specific to
a particular thread, or to a particular processor are they global?
What kinds of access are allowed? Is it simply query retrieval, or
might there be changes allowed? What's the availability of the data access?
Is it transient? Is it persistent that is could it be
long lasting as with the earlier connectors accessibility in terms of private,
protected or public. With respect to, to life cycle who is responsible for
doing the construction or building and who's responsible for
cleaning up when things are. Over think your instructors and destruction, and
as far as, cardinality is concerned who, who's responsible for
defining the messages and who's responsible for receiving them or using them.